farley was out of his mind even
off-camera right
you joined saturday night live they sent
you to the catskills to have some sort
of bonding weekend for the new cast and
farley comes running in
naked naked into your room yes farley
comes right and he had a tomato shoved
up his hands he had uh he said would you
like to see my impression of a salad
and he poured a salad dressing all over
his head and started shoving baby
tomatoes up his ass wow and did you
think this guy is the greatest or did
you think what the [ __ ] am i doing it
was the funniest thing i ever saw and
then he took me and he said i have to
tell you a secret yeah you know and i
was so like i was saying oh my god the
great farley has to tell me a secret you
know something about saturday night live
that i should know and it was a big big
resort and he finally found a room you
know that was and he on purpose looking
back on now he took all this time to
finally find a room and he locked the
door and he brought me in the corner and
he said this goes nowhere okay you know
this is between you and i
pat
is a woman
you see i'm interested in that you know
i laughed so hard that he would do this
for a stranger you know and that's why i
love farley so much and he's so much
different than all the rest of us is
that he would go down the street and uh
and just perform for everybody and i'm
telling you everybody loved chris farley
the young the old the the smart that's
what they say the stupid the people that
liked him the people that hated him yeah
you know we had a guy come in and do a
bad review on the show about how
horrible it was and how horrible farley
was and you know he laughed everything
farley said yeah yeah yeah
i wish so much you know he wanted to do
this show and i kept saying you got it
you got to do it you know i never met
that christmas
no you know he was one of those guys you
couldn't understand you know he kept
saying if only i could be as funny as
john volusia i said you're way funnier
than john i don't think i believe he's
funny i think he's like a serious actor
that was kind of like tortured but when
you see interviews with him he wasn't a
funny person
and and so
you know it always stuns me that a
person would be so unaware he's walking
through life and all he hears is
laughter i know and for some reason that
was the whole rap on farley who i didn't
know but every one of you guys who was
friendly with him say that he was just
crazy he was the funniest guy in the
room and he just never felt like he was
worth anything yeah and even with the
success of those films and you know just
he just felt like an unfunny guy but i
do remember him telling me you know when
he was a boy you know his father was
like 600 pounds i didn't know that and i
remember him telling me that as a boy he
would walk with his father and and
all he would hear was the
the talk you know
people goofing on the dead yeah yeah
that was his sadness young boy and i
don't think that ever left him
yeah well you know i mean although
sometimes i'd watch his physical humor
and he was getting big like i mean
really yeah he turned beat red i
remember one time chris we were in the
rehearsal and you know it was a
breakaway table you know and he his
thing was falling into the table so i
said how the [ __ ] how the [ __ ]
you fall without putting your hands out
yeah you know so uh we all tried it you
know
and uh none of us could do it if you
fall forward you're just automatically
automatically you've got to break your
fault you've got to break your file
because that's survival
and he didn't have um that's a biblical
survival instinct which made him so
funny and of course if you don't have a
survival instinct you're in trouble do
you think that's what his his demon was
the whole issue with his dad and stuff
and he was sad and that's what the drugs
did for him well
i mean he may
you know he may have
he may have had demons but uh you know i
considered him an angel because he
he would try to make everyone he
he encountered laugh also when we went
to the funeral we were shocked that he
had the second life in madison wisconsin
where he went to soup kitchens and uh
you know a very strict catholic and uh
his best friend was
named matt foley he was a priest which
he also named the character after and so
he had the second life of uh
uh you know where he
yeah
service to god